[موسيقى]
في الأيام الأولى من الحرب كان
وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي
شويغو على مرأى من الجميع
الوجه القديم والمعروف للجيش الآن في
الأسابيع الأخيرة كان غير مرئي تقريبًا
ويمكن رؤيته لفترة وجيزة في هذا الفيديو
الذي تم إصداره مؤخرًا  من خلال التلفزيون المملوك للدولة
ولكن ليس من الواضح متى تم تسجيله
أنه لا يرتدي زيه العسكري
ولا يتحدث ، لذا فإن التكهنات حول
موقف شويغو تتعارض مع
كل شيء يتعلق بسمعة
الجيش الروسي ،
لذا يجب أن يكون كذلك  في الوقت الحاضر ، يجب أن يكون
مرئيًا لهذا السبب بالذات ،
ولم يدخل الحرب بقوة وراء
موقف روسيا من أوكرانيا
حتى مع تقدم جيوشه في المستنقع
وتزايد عدد الضحايا ، أخبر بوتين في
11 مارس أن كل شيء يسير وفقًا
لخطة
ولائه لـ  يُنظر إلى بوتين على نطاق واسع على
أنه لا يتزعزع علاقتهما التي
تمتد لعقود من الزمن لتشمل ليس
فقط العمل ولكن أيضًا الإجازات المشتركة
لركوب الخيول وصيد الأسماك والاسترخاء في
العد الروسي  ryside كان
دائمًا مخلصًا للغاية لبوتين لم
يشكك أبدًا في أفعاله
ولم يُظهر أبدًا أي طموحات بأن يصبح
شخصًا أكبر بكثير من وزير
الدفاع ، وهذا هو الشيء الذي يجب عليه البقاء لورد
بوتين حتى الآن عندما طلبت
CNN من متحدث باسم الكرملين شرح الاختفاء المفاجئ لـ shoigu ،
كانت الإجابة مقتضبة
وزير الدفاع لديه الكثير
في الوقت الحالي ، ليس هذا هو
الوقت المناسب للنشاط الإعلامي بالضبط ، وكل ذلك يأتي
في أعقاب تقرير لرويترز يفيد بأن شخصًا
آخر في بوتين قد استقال من
وظيفته وغادر البلاد بسبب الحرب مع
أوكرانيا
إلى  الآن يخمن أي شخص ما
حدث لوزير الدفاع ، كل ما
نعرفه حقًا هو أنه يبدو أنه
يفتقد إجراء بدون
تفسير حقيقي لماذا
توم فورمان سي إن إن
واشنطن وفريد ذكرتم ماريوبول ليس بعيدًا عن
[ __ ] ، أفهم أن لدينا جد
دًا  مقطع فيديو من تلك المدينة التي تعرضت
للدمار خلال الأسابيع القليلة الماضية ، تحدث
إلينا حول ما نراه ،
نعم بالتأكيد أعني أنه
في البداية مشهدًا مدمرًا هناك في
ماريوبول تلك المدينة الواقعة تحت الحصار ،
يكاد يكون من المستحيل على الناس
الدخول والخروج من هناك بعض
الممرات الإنسانية التي عملت إلى حد
ما ولكن أعني أن بعض مقاطع الفيديو
التي تظهر للتو تظهر
الدمار التام في  هناك ، وإذا ألقينا
نظرة عليها
لثانية ، فأنت تعلم أنني أريد
فقط أن يشاهدها مشاهدينا
وسأظل صامتًا لبضع لحظات فقط عندما تشاهد ذلك بالسيارة عبر ماريوبول
مع الدمار التام هناك.
[موسيقى]
لذلك ترى أن هناك جثثًا
ترقد هناك أه سيارات مدمرة وليس
مبنى واحدًا يبدو أنه
لم يمس ، كما
تعلم ، لم أر شيئًا من هذا القبيل
منذ أسوأ أيام الحرب السورية التي
غطت على نطاق واسع مثل
ماريو  بول بالتأكيد في وضع مؤلم
، لا يزال الناس محاصرين بالداخل هناك
بالطبع في خطر كبير حيث
تواصل تلك القوات الروسية
إطلاق النار هناك جون